boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very excited to be talking about robots
Rockets comedy we have former rocket
scientists now comedian Imran G what's
up man what's up man how you doing
thanks for coming out of the show thank
you so much for having me really pumped
really pumped there's a lot to unpack
here this is an interesting career yeah
and for those who don't know Imran G's
background you can find his link in the
bio below Imran G calm but the
background is former rocket scientist
for 11 years Lockheed Boeing United
Launch Alliance Launch Alliance ula and
now stand up comedian writer host bad
Asians show podcast also open for epic
people like Robin Williams and Schumer
etc so let's let's jump into things on a
big history perspective we always like
to start this way so alright humans find
themselves after a long period of
evolution as stewards of earth okay what
is your current synthesis of the state
of humanity oh my god those are so many
words that I don't understand in a row
okay let me unpack this what is the
synthesis to where we are currently
that's what you want to know alright I
think we're in a state of disarray right
now I feel like there's a lot of
different ideals that are kind of like
bubbling up and then coming up at a past
so I think it's a very interesting time
to live in I also think it is kind of
scary depending on what side you're on
do I think this is the end absolutely
not
but I do think that humanity as a whole
needs to start coming together otherwise
we're gonna be screwed in a really large
way am I allowed to cuss on it
absolutely okay yeah we're gonna be
[ __ ] if we don't start doing [ __ ]
about what's going on and that's that's
how I currently feel what is
specifically the malevolence
that is causing the the [ __ ] and then
what is the [ __ ] that we have to do in
order to solve it alright I think we
need to really tone down our fossil fuel
usage because I do believe it is having
an effect on the environment based off
of the discussion that we were having
earlier where it is cold as [ __ ] in San
Francisco right now you've been here for
how long seven years yeah it hasn't been
40 degrees before ever ever and I know
there are people probably watching this
like 40 is shorts weather you're not to
us not to us
but yeah so it's like something is
happening and I really from the little
that I read and when I say little I mean
little it seems like the environment is
getting to a point where we can still
fix it but we are it seems like on the
eve of an event horizon where we won't
be able to actually fix the planet the
way that we want it to be or maybe to
the point where we believe it should be
if we do nothing so we should cut down
our fossil fuels probably stop eating as
much meat if we can just try to make our
footprint smaller in every way possible
which is asking a lot from people
because it means being mildly
inconvenienced which is the whole battle
I think yeah that's a pretty good point
is that it's a it's as we decrease our
footprint we kind of decrease our
degrees of freedom a little bit
technically for now because once we have
access to ubiquitous solar energy and
ubiquitous clean meat which can be grown
in bio reactors and we're not then
there's not really a there's the
footprint decreases and the degrees of
freedom stay the same or just
interesting but the thing you brought up
was inconvenience in people because we
you gotta actually realize that oh I
probably should just drink water in a in
a glass cup and wash it instead of use
plastic water bottles is a little kind
of quite simple yeah it's like you
should just have the foresight to have a
glass with you where you work as opposed
to like a smart water bottle
you know that you need to I mean if you
have a water bottle that you can refill
it's fine and anything that's like a
plastic cup or like when you go out to
eat and you just take a cup and then
throw that away or yeah the main thing
is I was thinking in particular about
straws because I've been using these
paper straws recently and they suck
they're they're not as good of a straw
as the plastic ones but I am willing to
make that sacrifice because I know it's
better
interesting so a lot of this is about
inconveniencing ourselves in the short
term all of us seven point eight billion
so that we can prosper in the long term
more effectively and also innovate the
solutions that we need now what would
you you know that was you know one of
the solutions that you know you're
providing a couple of these give us
another potential thing that we're doing
that you think that we should be solving
right now trying to think I'm thinking
about the way we have cities built are
terrible I think that they're all built
for cars and seeing how San Francisco
has changed within the last couple years
it seems that we will have to make
changes but a lot of people want to
transport around on scooters on you know
something that they could again it's a
disposable mentality it's like I need
this when I need it and then I don't
need it anymore so I want to put it
somewhere and then go somewhere else
just coming over for this thing I spent
30 minutes looking for parking in this
area you know and it's like if there was
a future where a city was built around
not having to get a car to come in to
find parking for all that it's like I
just needed to get to a Central Station
and then move around that way yeah it
would be a lot easier people want to
walk people want to be outside it's just
that our current the way we build cities
it's not built that way yeah that's a
good point about the structure of
Metropolis is the percentages of humans
that are living in metropolis is just
going up and up and up over time and the
way that we've designed these cities
this seems as though we are they have
1900
style design for 2000's style living and
so we've got to really take in like a
2100 style design into a mm i living
that would be ideal so like you
described these central transit points
some Asian countries have a yeah a
strong way of viewing things this way
and you'll like and also you you know
you bring up the income like you're
riding one of those scooters or bikes
these ride share these bike share or
scooter shares and then you you know you
drop it off when you're done using it
and then the next person comes and picks
it up in that area etc these are good
systems for shared for shared economy
and then we just got to you know figure
out the effectiveness of how to
incorporate this and we have to again
realize that if you want to have these
sort of benefits you are going to be
inconvenienced in some way which means
that if you're on a scooter put it back
you know I mean it's just I think about
when I walk down the street and I see
people like essentially just littering
with these scooters it's like if you
were a little bit better about this then
this wouldn't be a problem like can you
please I think about it the same way I
look at carts in a parking lot it's like
most people will take the car and put it
in that section that is meant for carts
yeah but there will always be a couple
[ __ ] who don't and they if that
becomes the general behavior that's when
we get in trouble sure that's bringing
in trouble yeah similarly with just
garbage
yeah go to the garbage cans yes instead
of just littering the inconvenience
yourself a little for the betterment of
humanity that's good that's really good
yeah so it's about these slight
inconveniences I like this perspective a
slight inconvenience on myself yeah like
not like even just holding on to your
own batteries etc just hold on to them
don't throw them in the trash just hold
on to them and then when you go with a
big load off to a battery recycling
station like you know I think that's a
good way to do it
alright let's um let's transition so you
know this has a lot the things that
we're talking about with bringing some
of these 21 hundreds principles into mm
sure this has a lot to do with robots
rockets and stuff and so you did masters
in aerospace engineering again and then
that's fun that's really fun how did you
figure out as a kid that you wanted to
do that as well as play with comedy
along the way oh man I my dad used to
work for a Martin Marietta which is now
Lockheed Martin and he got sent to Cape
Canaveral for a launch and so when I was
8 I saw a launch firsthand and it was
like the most amazing experience I had
ever seen it was just the fact that you
saw something sit there and then next
thing you knew like within 5 minutes it
was in space it like it blew my mind as
a child and so I immediately was like I
want to be an astronaut and that's kind
of the path that I had taken
you know I'd gotten a master's degree in
aerospace engineering I wanted to get a
couple of years of real-world experience
before I went got my doctorate but then
the Space Shuttle program came to an end
and so I was just kind of like okay what
what do I do now I was like I can
continue being an engineer but that's
kind of it's just gonna be more of the
same whereas I wanted to try something
different and I realized I always wanted
to do stand-up and so that's how I
started so thanks Obama such a cool
experience when you're eight you said
didn't you get to see the rocket in five
minutes be up in space that's super
exciting the thousands of humans that
were involved in in that process I'm
making that happen
so then yeah so then you got excited
about becoming an astronaut and then you
did aerospace engineering and then when
when was it that you were like I'm not
gonna become an astronaut I'm not gonna
do a PhD
um it was probably if my second year
into work so if you want to get a
doctorate or a higher degree I would say
just keep going till you get it because
once you start getting paid like a non
like student it's really hard to go back
yeah it's really hard to go back where
it's just like oh I I have to think
about what I eat now and I'm like do I
really want to do this if I can't be an
astronaut you know at this point and
that's one
I was like I don't I don't want to go
ahead with this this is all I need to
achieve in this round now as you're as
you're working in industry and you're
picking up these skills ula and Lockheed
and Boeing what are you learning as
you're there because this is satellites
as missiles this is all different types
of aerospace engineering projects yeah
so we dealt with I worked on a couple
different programs I did work on
missiles for a very short time but
usually satellites and rockets were
mostly what I worked on it's a lot of it
is just optimization or you know it's
integrating new technologies into what
we currently have so a lot of times when
we have we send a satellite into space
it takes months on end you know for us
to actually get it up there and so a lot
of times the way that technology is
jumps by the time we have Hardware up
there it's not the latest and greatest
it's crazy and to be honest it's never
the latest and greatest because we need
especially if you work on the military
side you need proven technology you need
a certain level of safety that just you
won't have on cutting-edge stuff and so
it's always a generation behind they if
you're making the satellite that is in
that you know they just went up the
transiting exoplanet survey satellite
let's say Tess and by the time you're
assembling it with all the components
and you're launching it up the newest
the newer components the hardware's and
software's are literally being made and
you can't you can't change the hardware
you can maybe update the sukkah software
right remote that's so nuts it is it's
really it's kind of aggravating to be
honest it's like especially as a person
who enjoys technology you're like this
is so old I remember on one of my first
jobs they were like oh there's this
older satellite that they wanted me to
train on to work on and I walked in I
turned on the computer and this was
maybe 2012-2013 and it said Windows 95
and I was like
my [ __ ] job I heard it was like this
nostalgic noise you know and I was just
like oh man this is so cool and I was
like wait a second this is still being
used like what this is insane but it's
like it is kind of fun because when you
design then you have to have this
foresight as to to look at the hardware
and be like what can it really do now
you know like what are what do we need
the system to do and even though the
system is old does it have the ability
to do what we needed to do and so that's
that's really where the job comes into
play very often I think we forget that a
lot of the money that we spend for
things like DARPA is AK actually goes to
the things that we have in our pockets
every single day absolutely this is
something interesting I think a lot of
people are very are very myopic in their
views and they don't see the long
picture which is that these things so
many of the components in here were
actually made by these large
governmental budgets and organizations
that were able to fund the scientists
and engineers that put together the
pieces that made Apple and Android and
Huawei and all these technologies around
the world soo so epic absolutely the GPS
satellites are free to use for everybody
and the the government keeps putting new
ones out and updating them I'm sure they
might be getting money on the back end
I'm not entirely sure all I know is that
they were originally for the United
States government yeah and that we just
get to use on our phones and I'm
grateful for it but also wondering what
else is on there you know yeah that's
right yeah that's right the a high level
of skepticism with actual like trust
based communication but also a high
amount of gratitude as well that the
technologies were made by so many people
and our in our taxpayer dollars that was
able to provide us with this instant
ability to find directions and to do all
this other work okay how about we we
touch on kind of like you know as we get
into comedy I want to do one more point
on some of the nuance here with with
rocket engineering the the space economy
is a very exciting transition that we're
heading to there's a lot of pieces of
space debris that we gotta like yeah
clear out of the way I believe it's only
several thousand satellites are
operational out of like almost 10,000
old one I've heard something like that
as well it's there's a lot of debris now
that's up there and so we've got to
clear some of that out to make the space
economy viable we have Virgin Galactic
and SpaceX and a bunch of these other
organizations even only wants to go up
and etc they want to go up and create a
the tourism space tourism so you can go
up and enjoy which is good because then
you can maybe gain an overview affect
perspective of Earth right and you can
open your love and compassion out to
more humans that way etc so and then of
course resupplying the International
Space Station going to the moon
colonizing that going to Mars colonize
it so tell us about your synthesis on
the space economy I think it is a I
think it's headed in the right direction
but I I think to call it a space economy
right now it's it's so far out we the
main problem that we have and continue
to have is power it's like how do we
efficiently leave escape velocity how do
we get into low-earth orbit without
expending so much energy where every
single pound counts sorry and so it's
what these companies are doing are great
and I do believe they're headed in the
right direction I think we are far off
from true space tourism and I think like
with Virgin Galactic all they really do
is take you just basically to the
outskirts of space where you're
weightless for minutes and then come
back down and that's 120 grand
it's I I don't think that's feasible it
would be great but in order for the
common person to get the experience
where you know you think about the earth
as a whole it has to be way cheaper than
that yeah like 120 bucks yeah 20 bucks
it would probably be even then that I
feel like that people would be like you
know that's that's Greyhound pricing
like what can I get
I don't know I 500 dollars I'd feel a
little bit safer leaving the atmosphere
then on on $120 flight you bring up this
really interesting point of being able
to take things up into low-earth orbit
the getting past the escape velocity and
there's there's this major issue is
being able to add more and more weight
to the payload that you want to deploy
and as you add more weight you need to
add more fuel and this is endless
process so then there's the idea of
having one booster
okay how about three boosters you know
it's add work the tailor so yes what is
what is it seems like burning like
liquid oxygen that yeah these sort of
methods of going up is for now what we
know
but yes potentially fusing hydrogen
could be effective no it is no like I
I'm on I'm on the team that we should
try everything yeah I you know we don't
know enough all we know is a method to
get into space it is clearly not the
best method there are a lot of things
that we can try and we haven't been able
to try and I think and I know you're
gonna set off from this but I think like
if we do have engines that need constant
monitoring if we do develop a eyes for
it you know it'll take a lot of the
guesswork in the math out of it if
something is constantly monitoring and
great for it and so I think I see the
technology
they're not at a point where they can be
integrated but I think it will happen
during our lifetime I love that point so
eventually we need to have algorithms
that are constantly monitoring the
dynamic state of that space systems to
to move the variables around and tweak
them as things are maybe coming a little
out of alignment yet they can
dynamically adjust and fix rather than
meeting humans to be watching this and
trying to do it that's very interesting
and then that could that can definitely
blow the space economy actually the
second that you take it out of a
person's hands it's just you flip a non
switch and the next thing you know
everything else is taken care of the the
faster that happens the easier we can
focus on everything else yeah you know
what I mean and but but that is the key
piece the second that it's easy to get
out of earth then all of these
possibilities open up but until that
process is made smoother and more
cost-effective and a lot easier in every
single way we're always going to keep
having these problems a huge point I
like that all right let's do our let's
do our transition more into the combi
side of things so all right so what what
have you found to be some of these so
many ways to do comedy and there's so
many ways that people get excited some
people love like hundreds of people in
the audience a trump ting and laughter
and them just going oh my god I gotta
keep doing this yeah some people some
people love being able to form some sort
of an artistic story arc in their mind
and then and then teach that to other
people
and then have you know the setup the
punchline all this stuff so yeah where
do you fit into into that I have started
getting much longer sets so I've been
lucky to be able to experiment more with
storytelling and to me that's the most
fun because it's yes you can do stand-up
punch or set up punch set up punch where
you put a set up and then you have a
punch line set up a punch line and
you'll get more laughs per minute
that way but I find OPM yeah there are
people you know there are comedians out
there who will sit there and take
measurements and data trying to figure
out how to increase because a lot of
people remember somebody telling me a
long time ago where it's like you want
to average somewhere around 8 laughs per
minute and I was like wait how did you
come up with that number like whose data
is this like what and they were just
like I just heard it was 8 and I was
like that's dumb
all right but yeah just take your own
audio recordings afterward and measure
I need more it's a low but I to me
that's just it's more structure and I
think that if you're starting that way
it's fine but after doing it for a while
you want to play with the structure
itself and so to me it's what I've
learned is the within reason if you stop
going for laughs per minute but try to
explain a viewpoint and then say your
punchline it will erupt much harder than
it would be if you had gotten
single-level laughs all the way through
and honestly if that's that's usually
when people remember anyway the big
jokes that might give me a way that you
would set up your story like how do you
first how do you get your material for
your stories and then how do you set
them up properly and then how do you get
to that bigger punchline to me I usually
try to figure out what I think is funny
like if I feel like something funny is
happening to me or some sort of a
relationship is going on that I
understand I can explain this in a funny
way that's usually how I go about it
because you can't I don't want to write
fictional stories so I wanted everything
from the storytelling perspective to be
true
whereas if I'm telling jokes then it
doesn't matter if it's truthful or not
because the point of that is to make
people laugh whereas the stories to me
are more realistic so a lot of times
like I I will have I will forcefully put
myself into situations hoping that
something will come
it I'm not trying to start fights at a
bar but it's just like I make a
conscious effort to be like I have to go
outside and I have to do something in
order to see if you know something
happens and one of the plus sides of
living that way is you actually get to
live a life you know trying to cultivate
this material it's just kind of what I
do so then you find these moments in
your life that you feel are solid
stories to tell and then you structure
them in a way that will take some sort
of maybe a moral lesson yes see there
are a moral lesson or a it's a lesson
that I needed to learn so a lot of times
it would be it I try to structure my
stories that there's some sort of
personal growth because I feel like
people are more on board with you
learning a lesson or learning a lesson
through you at your expense I think it's
a lot like people love to learn that way
and so it's kind of something that I've
only recently they're like if you [ __ ]
up but I learn I'm a hundred percent
okay with that and I'm like yeah that
makes sense
I forgot like the what is the phrase
it's like wise men learned from the
mistakes of others you know there's a
I'm going to my fifth 10-day meditation
retreat and it's Vipassana and no case
I'm going cos one of the main
disseminators of this okay with this
meditation tradition and what's very
funny is there are these lectures in the
evening videotaped lectures and he has a
story in one of the videotaped lectures
where he teaches that when I have when I
have my watch and you have your watch if
you drop your watch and the ground and
it shatters and it's a very rare watch
hard to find the pieces the I lecture
you I give you a sermon you should be
more careful with your watch and cetera
but if my watch false I cry I cry my
watch oh my god my watch and so it's
these attachments these things and it's
these like you said there's these
powerful moral lessons that we can teach
other people and have them prevent
potentially making mistakes especially
really important too you know
belts and kids as we enter into more of
a crazy or exponential technology age we
can teach kids these robot proof
skillsets
social emotional intelligence and stuff
like that so what have been some of the
cool more lessons that you like teaching
about let's see some stuff of it is some
of it is race a lot of it is just
understanding different viewpoints it
would be usually either religion related
or like I said race related is a big one
but my what I'm trying to tell people is
I it's you can be different and that's
fine but we need to find a middle ground
like like we're all human yeah it's just
I for some reason I feel like whenever I
watch TV people just think in extremes
now like there's no middle ground for
anything and that if I disagree with you
I am against everything of what makes
you you you know and I mean it's like
all of a sudden if I disagree with you a
lot of people have interpreted that like
that person has a problem with me and
the answer is no I just think something
else on maybe this one thing take it
personally yeah there's dehumanization
that are yeah that's that's been the
biggest part it's like somehow with the
evolution of the internet we've made
tribal mentality so extreme right now
where it's there's too many tribes and
everybody has a voice and nobody wants
to be it just reminds me of like India
before like way back when where it's
like there's just all these small little
tribes everywhere and that if everybody
just kind of put their differences aside
and come together it's like you could
form one large you know country or the
United States you know we had our
different states or a planet or a planet
that would be afresh absolutely where
were the [ __ ] in charge you of the
division I wish we would get attacked by
aliens because that is the only way that
people will be like you know what fine I
don't care about this and now you're
talking false flag stuff if we get
attacked by aliens it has to be the
real alien and not the
reverse-engineering that the governments
of okay frighten us into coming together
to be enslaved for this false alien I
agree with that but also if there was a
government program that went wrong and
people thought it was an alien and then
we banded together and then found out it
wasn't I would be okay with that - yeah
require us discover another a species
outside of Earth to realize that we are
all one tribe but okay so we see like we
started talking a bit on these you know
some of your moral lessons are around
race and religion which are again you're
trying to find a common ground on the
ground of humanity and then on the same
end of things you're you're
simultaneously viewing the way that
technology is affecting our discourse
yep yeah this is really important yeah I
I'm still trying to work out the kinks
I'm trying to figure out how I could
properly express that AI is bad if you
think of it in terms of the way we live
our lives now like it is totally
replacing jobs it is but it's not
supposed to replace a person it's
supposed to replace the mundane work
that we don't want to do nobody wants to
do their job you know people want to
work people want to have a job but most
people's job they they're it's not a
pleasurable experience I would say 80%
of the time so if we can reduce all that
other stuff where you get to do what you
want to do and then ultimately and this
is a pipe dream right now where it's
like everybody just kind of creates some
version of art and then you get to pick
and choose whatever art you want to see
it just people don't have to be just an
accountant anymore
you could be an accountant for a while
and a stand-up comic or a playwright or
you know you could do multiple things
it's just that if a lot of your needs
are already met and being done by
something else that shouldn't be
threatening to you it should be in
because it gives you more time to do
whatever it is that you really want and
that could even be nothing you could
just watch Netflix and eat other
people's art yeah if that's what if
that's what you want to do you want to
consume other people's art and have that
make some sort of an image in your mind
versus maybe create it yeah sure
yeah I've realized this to really slow
down a lot on judgement and stuff I
always say like go and create create
don't just consume etc but if humans
really want to just consume and that is
their thing then you know you get to
spend your life doing whatever you want
to do period as long as it doesn't
damage other people's lives okay so I
mean you're now you're transitioning us
into the stuff yeah exactly so yeah so
let's so let's take that on okay as we
find ourselves as stewards of Earth this
this law of accelerating returns is
impacting biotechnology neuro technology
artificial intelligence from quantum
computing is erupting right
cryptocurrencies blockchain technologies
it's all over the fields and where do
you see us now how do you see us
synthesizing the extech fields with our
human values of compassion love heart
centricity how do we do that see that's
that's rough and I think the more you
have to depend on humans the more it's
gonna go wrong like I I honestly believe
this because and I'm gonna explain this
when people have different in opinion
people cannot I would love to hope that
everybody comes and finds a middle
ground but some people enjoy this they
live to argue they live whatever's going
on in their life that's their main
motivator and that's their main outlet
so it's hard to try to get all these
systems working as they should be
because it kind of comes in with this
natural I call like common good law and
it seems that like a lot of times when
there is a common good like let's take
these
scooters for instance it's like common
good says you'll put them back where
you're supposed to or in a place that's
out of the way but because of his human
interaction they just throw it literally
right in front of the store and then
walk right in and it's like how do you
appeal to these people how do you teach
them what is common good because if they
don't adhere to that it doesn't matter
what AI does what it's always going to
be an issue
I think the the key is to try to figure
out how do we create a system that
learns to live the way that we do like
it has to adapt to us as if as opposed
to us adapting but we're not doing it
very good we're not really setting a
good example I just know I I agree with
that and I think that's where the actual
problem is it's like how do how do you
teach people to be better let's see if
we can tackle this from two ways one of
one of the ways to tackle it is this
developing our own ethics our own morals
our own value systems as humans yeah and
building those up and up over time and
then then that will be more reflected in
the way we build our technology and our
communication systems and so then now
build-out and then I think let me see
correct me if I'm wrong here with your
perspective but I think you're speaking
like a true scientist and as as as do I
speak this way as well that just sheerly
a computational system that is much
greater than the computational power of
the mind can crunch trillions of
variable simultaneously that are all
dynamically adjusting like what a
civilization is and it can just more
easily make decisions with more
information right then human minds can
for now and so there is a little bit of
of a power shift that also needs to be
made Hey
like just you may not be dropping off
these scooters and bicycles in the
proper location right now so what we
will do as this massive computational
infrastructure is we will figure out
either where to relocate some of the the
drop-off pickup stations we will figure
out how to automate the process of
dropping off and picking up these things
right cetera
absolutely but going back to your first
point how do you teach ethics on a
global scale every country is different
every person is different everybody has
a different mix of cultural background
you know upbringing what race you are
what sex you are it doesn't matter you
know everything is different how do you
teach ethics that everybody is on board
with and who gets to make those
decisions is it something that's
government lis mandated is it something
that we need to do as a collective
through a new religion as to speak like
how do you what are your thoughts yeah
that's a really good question and I'm
glad you brought that up
you know a Nassim Nicholas Taleb talks a
lot about scaling ethics okay because
for example in your family you're
actually quite socialist like you'd
you're very open to giving your family
money they're very open to giving you
money etc as you need in your community
you're a little bit more like democratic
you're like you know you want you will
help they will help etc etc and then
once you get to like the global level
it's much harder to scale your ethics to
you're a little bit more conservative
you're like hey hey before you come into
our community can we at least learn
about your history because if you are a
rapist if you are an aggressive
assaulter can't have you coming into our
community and so then there's these
protocols that have to be in place about
building trust about governance and
things like that and then so that's the
scaling of ethics and the question
becomes how do you get to a socialist
style of ethic with everyone across the
planet yet simultaneously incentivizing
innovation art entrepreneurship so
there's still a strong the baseline
raises up so that the rich continue to
grittier while the poor
continue to get rich or really fast and
you kind of close this gap but everyone
keeps moving up over time so that's kind
of the question is how do we figure that
out and I think one of the best ways to
do that we touch this is the sense of
love and compassion and gratitude and
building that out because the more that
we dose up on that especially from this
grassroots level as well as this
top-down level they can meet in the
middle
mm-hmm but it's hard to it's hard to
teach it there's a bunch of different
ways to get up this mountain of an
awakening or enlightenment one of the
ways is meditation one of the ways of
psychedelics one of the ways is just
compassionate practices of love and
gratitude volunteering in cetera so we
got to figure out what's our best way as
in each individual to go up and what are
we gonna do with the current ruling
class that likes having sex with
children like if they're and if you know
they want to normalize that which I
would lean a little more towards it's
not in our best interest for children to
be taught sexual activity by grown
adults
yeah then they're doing that that was a
valid thing that one is a there's
there's a we don't deny that first of
all can we all agree that it's possible
that there is a ruling class among us
that has a strong pedophilia file I mean
we can say it's conspiracy theory or we
can just you know not easily dismiss it
and understand that it could be possible
and there could be you know crazy I
don't even need to say it's a conspiracy
theory because it already it's already
happening in the Catholic Church in some
ways and yeah all right so just just to
just to as you know as we talked about
that there are some there are some ways
of fixing certain mental health issues
with transcranial magnetic stimulation
there's there's other ways of fixing
with great computer interfaces there's
all different types of ways to tweak and
edit certain ways of behaving that are
malevolent which can which are being
explored and will continue being
explored in the next couple of decades
what would you you know as we talk about
this as we talk about these ethics
evolving across the planet from you know
from both sides of the equation from
high SES low SES etc what would be your
ideal civilizational design how could
things be designed where you would see a
maximization of flourishing
I don't have a definitive answer to that
but I will tell you this I was I went to
Japan six months ago
and I went to Nagoya the first time I
don't have you been to Nagoya at all um
so it was a city that was 100% destroyed
in the war and so Japan built it from
the ground up and so I found it very
interesting because it meant that it was
built I I don't know what your was built
but I'm gonna guess it ain't sure no it
was way after that cuz its own agora
nagoya japan not but not post-world War
two but not post-world War II I think I
think it might have been no it was
destroyed because they built the
airplanes there but I don't think we hit
it with the nuclear bomb yeah it wasn't
near her ocean we're not talking you
know but it was still destroyed sometime
in the later 1900s yes okay and then
they built it from Italy build it from
the ground up oh yeah it was very
interesting because what they have is a
subterranean network of subway systems
and the subway itself it has like a
whole mall underneath the whole city and
so when it does is there are lanes for
cars upstairs like on you know on the
road but most of the city is built
around bikes and walking and because a
large percent of what happens is
underground the weather doesn't matter
at all so it's like even on days where
it was pouring there was like a healthy
lively city and you could easily get
from one point of the city to another
because everything was run underground
and it was kind of enclosed it was a
little bit claustrophobic but it just it
was such a great utilization of space
and to me since the city was built and
one was have city built
I can pull up my phone this is very
interesting because the city itself the
architecture like you're describing it's
right by Kyoto and Osaka interesting but
it's built from gory I mean they
essentially have like a whole floor of
Nagoya underneath the city and as a
result it's a great utilization of space
it's small shops that I heard that the
the rent is not super expensive so it
facilitates a lot of locally owned kind
of farmers areas it's just it's a really
well thought out system where it's like
once you get in you can find anything
that you need underground regardless of
what the weather is underground
underground interesting and it's just
it's a system that the transit system is
one of the best that I've ever seen I
was just looking at this nose like this
is what happens when you refuse to build
on top of a city and just start from
scratch yeah yep and it's just if you
guys ever get the chance just travel
around it's so easy to get around
everywhere there and it's so clean
that's huge the cleanliness the easiness
to get around says 1956 designated a
city then World War 2 and later 1942 was
flooded in 1959 was flooded by a typhoon
that's where I wanted to say it was
built in the later half of the 1900s the
latter half mmm-hmm and so as a result
there's a lot of things going on there
and it's just really well-organized I
didn't see a lot of traffic the subway
systems got a little full around five
o'clock when everybody got off of work
but that's to be expected but other than
that it was just smooth sailing
everywhere people have been saying that
about Japan for a long time about the
way that their design and engineering is
just so cutting edge yeah like this is
there yeah those are systems that we're
on it's it's also extremely interesting
to think about city design like you're
talking about how to maximize like it's
it's cold Nagoya and Japan can get cold
and so to put things under ground isn't
potentially more
active for those like six months of
colder temperatures and also then just
if you look at this if you look at this
when you look here look at when you look
at Nagoya look at this transit station
transit station transit station look at
all these and this is in the outer spoke
of the sphere so it's made like like a
wheel is having spokes for transit and
it's just like it's you can get along
you can get anywhere and it's not that
hard it's really not that bad and now
with Google Maps it's like I don't even
have to speak the language it's like the
maps will just show me where to go and
it's again one of those things where I
say once the system is built you know
it's it's easier to utilize I think I
think it's it's like San Francisco it's
like the city burned we built on top of
that then there was like some sort of
earthquake do you know can we built on
top of that and it's like what would the
city look like if we got a chance to
build it from zero yeah we're gonna get
that cheer and say okay now with the INF
treaty gone to [ __ ] and nuclear warheads
are back in action bring that [ __ ] ah
yeah
or you know just find someplace in I
don't know Arizona and build it from the
ground up and see what it looks like
there long as they are there they're
trying to do that with uh I know Google
has tried but I don't city is it there's
there's a city called a croissant II
okay right now so what does that look
like it's they're taking a little while
with it so here's a town it literally in
Arizona but this is kind of the
experimental town with molten bronze
Bell casting to demonstrate how urban
conditions could be improved while
minimizing the destructive impact on
earth and then so here's what kind of
like here's a view of Arcosanti the
cliff view no no so here's kind of like
a
yeah anyway what what is interesting
although although you're you know you're
right there with look there's a lot of
variables that are coming into this
equation that needs to be crunched in a
way that makes sense for example we
already have a large demographic of
people that have moved to the Bay Area
for the network effects and whatnot
so it's it's like you know one of the
only ways to do it is like Ron said
figure out a way to completely clean the
slate and then to rebuild it all in this
area because people already live here
and how to do that in the span of like
three months or something Island death
verse for a part so that is the answer
is a part and another another
interesting way to think about it is
could you move everyone in the Bay Area
down towards South even south of like
Monterey somewhere between LA and SF and
could you build the city there in three
or six months and then move everyone
there its cetera there's there's
different ways to think about it one of
the ways again to practice thinking
about it is to do things like run these
experiments in your own design so you
could take computer-aided design and you
could start building out the transit
systems and the building's themselves
and etc and then that way you can make
your own cities and then when you can
get into indistinguishable virtual
reality so you can just bring your
digital body into those places and start
playing and whatnot
but for these cities it just boils it
goes back down to my point where I was
saying that they will eventually
calculate what the correct amount of
space per person is and no matter it's
probably gonna be less than what you
think it is it's like 300 square feet
that's what I'm saying and are you
willing to be inconvenienced for that in
order for society to move forward and I
think that's to me that's always been a
point of it where it's like we will be
inconvenienced to gain a convenience
elsewhere that's it and the question is
are you willing to make that trade-off
everyone is moving to these metropolis
so not everyone but a lot of people are
moving to Metropolis and and they're
willing to be inconvenienced like
circling all the way back in order
to be around stronger network effects so
they're willing to take a 300 square
foot apartment as long as they have
access to you know the the central areas
of parks and a kind of high network
individuals that they can go in or be
able to have access to art like comedy
shows like the bad asian show like all
of the great shows that we have in San
Francisco all the plays all the all you
know just a lot of the culture like you
need to have everything and I believe
that you know by allowing people to
understand that they will be
inconvenienced but will be convenience
in other ways I think that's the main
cell yep now okay couple quick questions
on the way out Jim run what would you
say is a core driving principle of your
life to constantly move forward and not
to be put into a particular box to do
things that are interesting to you and
then not caring about what other people
think you know a lot of times people
don't understand that I could have a
creative pursuit and have a technical
job at the same time and they're like
how do you balance it and it's like well
if you want to do something you'll make
time for it and both sides of the coin
make me happy in some way and to
continue to do that should be a it's a
conscious effort on my part and I feel
like everybody needs to do both like
even if you're a creative do something
that forces you to be logical you know
so you can think you know problem-solve
out and if you are a problem solver take
classes that force you to be creative
even if you're bad at it the whole point
is we each individual needs to be more
well-rounded so we can be well-rounded
as a society we need to stop being like
we need to do this and then having no
personal accountability it's like I want
to make sure that I am as well-rounded
as I can be and have a understanding of
as much as I can in order to be the best
you know member of society or
contributing member that I can be and I
just want I'm hoping that's the way
that's going to come
yeah how about yourself that's a good
one
it's I've been pointing at this a lot
recently it's the Nash equilibrium in
many ways it's the way that you can
yourself self actualize best while not
harming the collective but also keeping
the collectives uprising in mind so
there's an equilibrium to play out
between the individual thinking and
collective thinking that can maximize
flourishing and also like you mentioned
just well-roundedness in general it's
hard as we were talking about earlier
this this this notion of like this
non-judgmental thinking if someone wants
to just be super eccentric and in a cave
and just working on technical stuff as
long as the idea doesn't just die with
them because they we want at least for
that edge of knowledge to be pushed and
then for someone to come and help
disseminate it to the rest of
civilization but I think it's it can be
weird sometimes forcing social-emotional
skills on highly eccentric people or or
the opposite way is for highly emotional
highly creative people to be like hey
understand a little bit about logic as
well so they can be tough but I also
totally get the well-roundedness is very
important and there's not enough that's
being explored I will give you this we
shouldn't force them to be that way but
I think for the people to be ignorant as
to how other people think I think is not
okay that's it
yeah yeah it's other people you might
not understand rational thinking but you
need to understand how it works so you
can understand how this person thinks
Thanks yeah how other people think
because then that's how that's how you
understand how civilization roles pieces
right work together the humans in the in
the puzzle if everybody understands that
this person is an eccentric and this
person understands that they're
eccentric and is able to at least talk
to those people on some level that that
if that's what that community is okay
with and that's what they're okay with
yeah I mean like we don't the police
every holder we total it just needs to
be understand and understand a cop we
need to be we need to have a common
understanding of some sort with everyone
our common humanity at least and that
common love and the common prosperity
Emran how about we asked you are we in a
simulation I think about this every once
in a while and the question that I have
always had is not are we in a simulation
but if we are in a simulation who has
programmed it to work in their benefit
you know I mean because it's clear to me
if if we're both simulation if we're in
a simulation we are not winning on the
level that we should be winning if we
were programming it you know I mean like
you would assume that you would have
like an abundance of funds abundance of
like you can literally do whatever you
want that's what it means to me to be in
a simulation so I can't say for sure all
I know is that if there is a simulation
I'm probably working on it but it's not
mine does that make sense yeah you're
part of it I'm part of it but I'm not
I'm not clearly like this is jay-z's
simulation because you know someone like
that or like someone like Beyonce was
just like winning on every level that
you can see it's like okay maybe then
mm-hm
but like if I was running a simulation
why would I give myself a nine-to-five
mm-hmm does that make sense yeah of
course if you were if it was run by you
you would maximize flourishing for yeah
and ferb for preferably everyone period
max my flourishing for everyone as best
as you could but then who is it actually
simulated by is the question because
then are what other motives exist in
this equation we're gonna get in trouble
for talking about this and my thing is
always like who's succeeding the most if
this is a simulation mm-hm
and then try to see if why it's that way
lead pipe to the head this last question
yeah what do you think's the most
beautiful thing in the world you know I
want to say something cliche like a
sunset or something like that but it's
not to me it's
it's honestly like seeing people happy
like truly happy
like just uncannily unconditional love
but just when somebody has true
happiness and you catch it even when
it's on like film or like you know on
YouTube it to me I think that's the most
beautiful thing to see someone genuinely
happy whatever it is that to me is the
most beautiful thing in the world which
is still kind of cliche but I don't know
I just I like seeing people be happy you
know yeah that's great yeah yeah across
across all different walks of life yeah
yeah and across all different emotions
of happiness feelings of happiness
it could be just somebody seeing their
kid for the first time in a long time it
could be like you know a dog seeing its
owner for the first time in a while
yeah could be anything it's just that to
me is the most beautiful thing I love it
how about yourself listen sir I asked
you the crime not used to this man oh
it's just all one-sided but it's been
fun yeah I'm glad I'm glad that you've
had a baby you've had a fun time this is
very important to us thank you so much
thank you so much on the show absolutely
very enlightening across a lotta
different aspects robots Rockets all
different kinds of interesting stuff was
discussed it had a great time yes good
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate you so much we'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below let
us know what you're thinking also check
out MMD's links below and keep
supporting artists and entrepreneurs
that you believe in you support them
around go to this shows you support your
local artist go to their art exhibits
you support your load of local
entrepreneurs like simulation that are
making this content support us links are
below support your local artists
entrepreneurs everyone do it do it do it
for the common good of mankind give him
more money we'll double your pay after
this and thank you everyone again for
tuning go and build the future everyone
go and manifest your destiny into the
world we love you so much thanks Ron for
producing and directing we'll see you
soon
peace